hi everyone I'm Maurice Samuels the
director of the Yale program for the
study of anti-Semitism and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to the first
event of the 2023 24 Academic Year I was
on leave last year which was great but
I'm also very happy to be back hosting
these events uh this year some events
are going to be on zoom and some are
going to be in person but we're going to
be broadcasting the live events on Zoom
as well so I urge everyone to check out
the ypsa calendar of events on our
website and get on the mailing list I'm
especially excited to introduce today's
speaker Martha Hodes uh since she was
the interim director of the Doris and
Lewis B Coleman Center for Scholars and
writers at the New York Public Library
where I had my fellowship last year um
so I had uh the chance to have many
conversations with Martha as she
finished this book um she's now back to
her regular day job as professor of
history at NYU where she she specializes
in American history of the Civil War
she's the author of many books including
white women black men elicit sex in the
19th century South the Sea Captain's
wife a true story of love race and War
in the 19th century and mourning Lincoln
which won the Lincoln prize in
2016 actually all of her books uh have
won awards and made many best book of
the year list when they were published
Martha is a past recipient of the
gugenheim fellowship and has many other
distinctions that I won't attempt to
list because I'm so eager to hear her
talk about her fascinating new book my
hijacking a personal history of
forgetting and remembering published by
Harper Collins this past spring before I
hand it over to Martha let me just
explain how things will work today uh
Martha is going to speak for about 35 or
so minutes I think uh then we'll open it
up to questions from the audience please
submit your questions to me using the
Q&A function at the bottom of your
screen and I'll do my best to ask as
many of them as I can uh we can't see or
hear you however and the chat function
is disabled so please only use the Q&A
function and you can send questions as
soon as you think of them you don't have
to wait for the talk to be over you can
just start sending them to me um okay so
that's it for the housekeeping and I
will now hand it over to Martha thank
you thank you so much Mory and thank you
for this opportunity to present to this
group and I thank everybody for tuning
in everyone who's with us today well as
maybe was clear from Mor's introduction
I've never written a book like this one
my hijacking a personal history history
of forgetting and remembering I'm a
historian of the 19th century United
States and all my other books focus on
race and the Civil War era the most
recent uh a book about personal
responses to Lincoln's
assassination my hijacking like my other
books is based on deep archival research
but here I also intertwine my own
memories and my own research into family
history this book for those of you who
haven't read it is about the hijacking
of three planes in September
1970 the hijackers were members of the
popular front for the liberation of
Palestine a radical Marxist leninist
faction too radical even for the
Palestine Liberation Organization the
PLO I was 12 years old at the time a
passenger on one of the planes I was
traveling with my 13-year-old sister
Katherine and we were unaccompanied by
adults we were returning to New York
from Tel Aviv
my mother had moved to Israel to help
start the beta Dance Company under the
direction of Martha Graham my parents
were both former principal Graham
dancers and my sister and I spent our
childhood summers in Israel and I'm just
going to share a couple of images with
you that's me on the left in the summer
of 1970 at my mother's Tel aveve
apartment building and then my sister
Katherine and me practicing our yoga
poses on the beach and that photo on the
right was taken the day before we
boarded the plane
home Katherine and I were held hostage
in the Jordan desert inside the airplane
for a week our captors hope to exchange
the passengers and crew for Palestinian
Prisoners the book then is something of
a hybrid about my own participation if
unwitting in a world hist historical
event what I'd like to do this afternoon
is is offer to you various parts of the
manuscript with interjections for my
listeners here today so to begin I will
set the scene at the
outset Sunday before Sunrise everything
is dark and quiet in our Tel Aviv
neighborhood we packed the night before
and now my mother helps us close the
tops of our identical gray
suitcases at L Airport not much more
than a single building we come to an
ascending stairway with a big bon vage
sign hanging above from there Travelers
must proceed alone and when we arrive at
that stairway my mother puts on her
sunglasses she is crying because she has
to say goodbye to us for a long
time I like that memory something about
it parallels my favorite book in the
summer of
1970 my Israeli stepfather had given us
the Little Prince with an intriguing
cover illustration of a young boy
standing on a Barren planet with a
miniature volcano first my stepfather
read the story to us then I read it to
myself Enchanted by the lonely Aviator
narrator whose plane crashed in the
desert and the downcast boy Wanderer he
met there that boy The Little Prince
bids farewell to a temperamental flower
a rose he loves very much of course I
love you the rose tells the Little
Prince it is my fault that you have not
known it all the while she implores the
boy to be happy and asks him not to
linger for she did not want him to see
her
crying I read the book twice more until
I had it nearly memorized in my diary I
wrote it is
fantastic in various parts of the book
then I interweave quotations from The
Little Prince which appear in the text
in parentheses and you will hear some of
these in the next while as I'm speaking
with
you to continue from a bit further
on takeoff from Frankfurt is right on
schedule at 11:02 a.m. less than an hour
later As we soar over Belgium the
captain announces an altitude of 28,000
feet with Brussels visible on the left I
hear a commotion shouting that sounds
Angry Words I don't understand now a
woman is running up the aisle a man
follows both of them
shouting some passengers think a husband
and wife are having a violent argument
others that the woman is air sick
running to the bathroom to
vomit I see only a blur but Katherine
sees the man's gun others see the nickel
plated revolver too along with the
woman's finger inserted through the Ring
of a hand grenade I hope it's not the
Arabs gasps the old lady sitting in our
row clutching her heart she moans my
pills my pills prompting Catherine to
rummage through her handbag the old lady
warns my sister who's crying as she She
searches for the medicine to take off
the Jewish star hanging on a slim gold
chain around her neck the Purser still
thinks a man and woman are fighting with
each other and he runs after them
clapping a hand on the man's shoulder
the man turns points his gun and shouts
get back get back oh my God the purer
cries out I don't believe it just in
front of the curtain that leads to the
first class cabin the man in woman
turned to face the passengers shouting
hijack
hijack people speak urgently if quietly
some exchanging phone numbers and
pledging to notify family members should
only some of us
survive soon a woman's voice comes over
the loudspeaker which I record this way
in my
diary good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen I am the new pilot who has
taken command of your tww flight keep
calm please cooperate and put your hands
behind your
head Katherine and I copy the other
passengers raising arms and lacing
fingers I I wonder why the woman doesn't
tell us to put our hands over our heads
the way robbers do but she isn't trying
to prevent the passengers from drawing
weapons instead she needs all of us to
brace for impact in case something goes
wrong in the
cockpit The Landing is a greaser very
smooth with no damage to the aircraft
local time is 6:40 p.m. about a quarter
hour before
Sunset I let Katherine appraise the
situation leaning past me she peers out
the window at bill of dust and sand
which look like
smoke Commandos on the ground have
fashioned a makeshift Runway by lining
up barrels filled with sand and Diesel
soaked rags and the Blazing torches
light up people in military uniforms
which make it look like a
war someone props a ladder from the back
of a truck up to the plane's front exit
people dressed in fatigues Ascend the
ladder armed with flashlights and rifles
lanterns and machine guns some are boys
no more than 14 or 15 years old and some
are young women with short
hair the man and woman who took over our
flight climbed down triumphant Heroes
welcomed by their comrades melting into
the outdoor throng never to be
identified listening to my captors I
absorb both apology and
explanation in one imprinted memory I
watch Commandos carry thick yellow
cables the faces of the men
expressionless as they go about their
task
although I determin somehow that this is
dynamite there's no memory of
accompanying emotion only the sense of a
child intently watching every move again
I'm going to share a couple of images
with
you you can see here two of the three
hijack planes in the Jordan desert our
tww airliner on the left and the Swiss
airplane on the right in between flies
the Palestinian flag a few days later
later a British plane boac would join us
here you can see the three planes in the
desert when I began writing this book
many of my memories of the hijacking
were pleasant ones one day when
Katherine's diary was resting on her
tray table one of the Commandos spied
the heart she drawn on the back cover
with the name of the Israeli boy she
liked that summer eyes twinkling the man
exclaimed
romantic once when our captors let us
outside one of the Commandos joined the
children in a game of jump rope belt
clanging and military boots
thumping another day sitting in the
shade under an airplane wing someone
started around of John Denver's Leaving
on a Jet Plane which the folk Trio Peter
Paul and Mary had made into a hit single
that year loud voices among the singing
hostages changed the words to living on
a Jet Plane which Katherine and I
thought was hilarious and everyone was
laughing as we sang the line don't know
when I'll be back
again in the book I write about the time
in my adult life when I began to think
about the hijacking again it began right
after 911 and here I hasten to add that
there's no straight line from the 1970
hijackings to 911 after all the popular
front was a Marxist leninist
organization they were not Muslim
jihadists nonetheless a day of multiple
hijackings understandably unburied
memories and feelings soon after 911 I
was on my way to the University of
Michigan to give a
lecture I alerted my
host that I reserved the right to turn
around on the jetway if I couldn't bring
myself to board the plane a warning she
accepted without
question there was no need to reveal
anything more since in October 2001
people all over the world were afraid to
fly some on the flight cried cried
quietly others prayed visibly for the
first time in 30 years other people were
acting the way I always felt on
airplanes and that's when memories of
the hijacking began to
intrude right away I wrote down
everything I could conjure it was all
murky and there wasn't much and for the
first time ever I wanted to know
more telling the stories of our own
lives how can we answer the questions we
think to ask later on after the passage
of so much
time historian by trade I wanted to do
more than excavate just my own
memories with a Scholar's passion for
evidence and accuracy I wanted to
compare Recollections compare documents
and compare Recollections and documents
with each
other as a hostage I had quelled
memories and emotions as a historian I
wanted to search for facts and feelings
to provide meaning for everything that
had happened to me and my
family I dug farther into my own
memories and I put my memories together
with
Katherine's I began to talk with my
elderly parents taking note of my
father's carefully scripted stories my
Stepmother's more nuanced versions and
my mother's Misty
memories I found MOS my father had saved
some in my old room some in his self-
storage unit over on 11th
Avenue I talked with childhood friends
rekindling snuffed out conversations
about a topic I hadn't mentioned in
decades I asked friends from high school
college and Beyond if I'd ever even told
them I'd been
hijacked I visited archives read news
coverage and watched television
broadcasts I read the manifestos of my
captors and listen to their narratives
past and present I met and conversed
with fellow hostages I went back to the
places where everything
happened I wondered if I researched the
hijacking as a historian could that
Stamp Out the Absurd Sensation that none
of it had ever happened to me at all
could recovering the feelings that
accompanied the hijacking make real
something that felt so
unreal inside the plane I had my diary
with me and I wrote Every Day setting
down a little over a thousand words
during my desert
sojourn historians prize personal
writings that date from the time and
place under
investigation and when I started out I
was confident that my diary would be my
trusted scaffolding an in the- moment
account of everything that came to pass
along with my thoughts and feelings up
in the air in the desert at release and
upon
return in 1970 I named my journal Claire
writing my entries in the form of
letters in that technique I copied Anne
Frank who began her diary entries with
dear Kitty Anne Frank and I both wanted
to be writers and her birthday was the
same as mine
with a combination of ingenuousness and
self-consciousness I could be an
observant 12-year-old but rereading my
diary so many years later it became
clear that during that week in September
I had constrained my powers of
observation so much happened that I
never recorded it was as if I'd named my
diary Claire meaning clear as a way to
fool myself that I wrote my entries with
any
transparency I never wrote about the gun
I saw on the co-pilot's neck up in the
air I never wrote about the Commandos I
watched wiring our plane of dynamite the
night we landed I never wrote about the
time one of the women Commandos pointed
her gun straight at
me when my history students work with
firstperson historical documents whether
Diaries letters or courtroom testimony I
prompt them to ask why did this person
tell this story This
Way rereading my diary while writing the
book I saw that the aspiring writer in
me had constructed not a full record but
instead a tolerable story not an honest
story but instead a story I could tell
when I got home that Narrative of
omissions would comprise my version of
the hijacking and I would carry it with
me for years and years
afterward unsurprisingly then in the
course of my research I became aware of
aspects of the hijacking far less
Pleasant than much of what I remembered
for one there was a stream of weapon
Laden visitors who filed up and down the
narrow aircraft aisle some pointed to
the hostages and laughed others acted
like tourists taking in the sights
prompting one among us to joke that we
were the main attraction at the
Jordanian branch of the Bron
Zoo within sight too were tanks and
heavy artillery a reporter described
quote manned anti-aircraft and anti-tank
guns in trenches dug round the three
aircraft and a big Detachment of
gorillas armed with submachine guns and
Hand Grenades standing on the
alert we were surrounded in turn by
Jordanian Army troops signaling
signaling our position in a war between
Jordan and Palestinian
insurgents besides the guns and grenades
and armaments there was a dynamite and a
shifting
deadline a representative from the
International Red Cross came on board
one day to assure us that in his words
the entire world knows what's going on
here and that everyone was working on a
ution he then candidly added we don't
know if we will
succeed sometimes the Commandos would
tell us we cannot wait forever and you
will all go to a fiery death if this
thing isn't settled
soon Holocaust Survivors among the
hostages faced their own demons with
confinement and weaponry stirring up
unbidden memories only intensified by
the Troublesome construction of Arabs as
the new
Nazis one woman 38 years old had gone to
Bergen bellson in a cattle car her
father was murdered in binval and 10
aunts and uncles died in
aitz her captivity inside the hijack
plane brought me she would say later in
her broken English all the memories
again back from concentration camp which
was a very big
nightmare writing the book I set out to
discover the Contours of the demands of
our captors something I didn't entirely
understand at the
time sifting through community
Communications preserved in the Richard
Nixon Presidential Library in California
some marked top secret in the state
department archives in Washington in the
Swiss Federal archives and the British
national archives I set out to make
sense of the negotiations for our
release or its
opposite a document in the Nixon Library
quoted a spokesman saying the popular
front had brought explosives on board
ready to quote destroy the planes along
with their prisoners should the demands
of the popular front not be met by the
deadline I studied the document with
care to be sure I understood everything
correctly the spokesman quote hedged
when asked if the passengers would be
permitted to get off first but Guerilla
sources said the plan was apparently to
blow up the hostages also
unquote the commando's ultimatum was
repeated in another telegram quote time
period for meeting all of the demands is
72 hours if demands are not met within
this time planes with all passengers
will be blown up a Swiss official
described by a colleague as levelheaded
and not given to emotional talk noted
the serious possibility of quote a blood
bath in the
desert the weapons and the dynamite and
the deadline when I returned home I
would say I didn't really think about
that during my research as I learned
more about my fellow hostages I also
discovered something else
that my sister and I were different from
most of the other American Jews on our
plane my parents were my father's
parents my father's parents were in the
words of his brother worldclass
non-practicing Jews on my mother's side
My Grandmother Had refashioned herself
from Libby Yeta to Lily IET as part of
that transformation she spoke with an
affected British accent prepared ham for
Sunday dinner and bought Easter hats for
her granddaughters
our reason for traveling to Israel also
made my sister and me different this was
only three years after the 1967 war when
American Jews flocked to Israel happily
visiting the territories rested from
Jordan the old city of Jerusalem
including the Western Wall and the holy
sites of Hebron Jericho and Bethlehem on
the West Bank no one ever took Katherine
and me to those sites and the only
reason we were going to Israel was to
visit our mother in the words of one
dance
historian though of Jewish EXT exaction
Linda hods my mother had never been
interested in Israel or
Zionism when my mother and Israeli
stepfather took my sister and me to
visit friends in the artist colony of
inhad we had no idea that the hundreds
of Palestinians there in 1948 had been
exiled to refugee camps The Village soon
resettled by Israeli
artists in a letter home to our father
Katherine wrote painters printers and
sculptors live there in quaint little
Arab style houses enraptured and
entirely unaware of the history she was
describing everywhere are beautiful
mountain views and flowers she
wrote I had no idea that Palestinians
had once lived in Israel because many
Jews in 1970 had no idea
either the historian Omar bartov whose
Elders made their way from Eastern
Europe to Palestine lived he wrote next
to quote unquote abandoned Palestinian
villages but as a child he never once
those are his words considered the
origins of those
ruins nor did the Israeli kids we played
with have anything to teach us on this
count Israeli writer arish shavit around
my age noted that his grandparents and
parents proceeded with their lives as if
Palestinians quote never
existed Katherine and I were aware that
our captors wanted us to empathize with
them and we were interested in the
stories they told this is how we live
every day this is all we have to eat we
have no
homes and once again said The Aviator in
The Little Prince without understanding
why I had a queer sense of
Sorrow children trying to make sense of
global politics and human terms
Katherine and I stirred the new history
we had learned in the desert into the
history we already knew then stirred the
pain of our captors into our own fears
and the fears of our fellow hostages
in Israel our friend's parents had taken
Refuge from the Holocaust witnessed the
death of family and the loss of homes in
Europe escaping the destruction of the
Jewish people our captors Who Bore no
responsibility for the Holocaust had in
turn lost their homes in Palestine many
of them raised in refugee camps history
was the key yet each side told
completely different
histories what are your feelings toward
the gorillas now my father would ask
when we got home and I have conversation
on tape the Palestinians Katherine
corrects him no anger no resentment my
voice comes on the tape they have some
type of point which I didn't know before
I offer they have something they are
really trying to say and they need to
say it it's pretty sad my sister
continues I was very naive about the
political aspect I learned more a lot
more than I knew before per their
purpose was to get back their home she
explains and The Plea of any people to
get back their home is a valid
plea my sister and I puzzled out the
question could Israelis and Palestinians
live on the same land maybe it had once
been possible we thought but there was
so much anger now so much hatred that it
didn't seem possible anymore we couldn't
think of a
solution I stopped in my tracks my heart
torn aunder but still I did not
understand said The Aviator and Little
Prince there in the desert Katherine and
I just felt sorry for everyone
now in part the book traces my journey
toward understanding that my sister and
I had really been there inside that
plane in the desert held hostage for a
week in the national archives in
Washington I watched raw news footage
preserved by the CIA of our release
though at the time Katherine and I
didn't know where we were going where we
were being taken or what would happen
next it was early afternoon when we
arrived in a van at the Intercontinental
hotel in a man
Jordan watching the tapes I see some of
what I remember soldiers direct our
vehicle a Commando holds a megaphone
horns honk people speak in
Arabic 13 minutes in the tape switches
to the inside of the van passengers
displaying expressionless caution a
photographer had thrust his camera
straight into one of the open windows
and there we are and I'll show you an
image
here's a still
photograph I sit impassively hand to
cheek shielding me partly obscuring me
Katherine looks straight into the lens
serious responsible
Afraid on the tape she twists around to
look out the windows scanning the
commotion planning what to do thinking
how can I keep us from being separated
how can I keep Martha
safe tentatively then on the tape I look
around too right there on the screen
before my eyes is the 12-year-old girl
I've been trying to
conjure but there's that Feeling Again
despite all the documents despite all
the fellow hostages I've met and talked
to many of whom after all don't remember
Katherine and
me there's the feeling that the
hijacking must have happened to someone
else studying the moving image of that
girl makes me feel more than any
anything else like a historian coming
Upon A visual representation of her long
research subject for the first
time watching the tape all those years
later I write down I can't believe I was
there I'm going to dedicate this next
passage about our arrival at Kennedy
Airport to my father who died at the age
of 98 before he had a chance to read the
book of course I could have given him
the manuscript at any point but I never
did
I see my father before he sees us he's
so pale that the words white as a sheet
leap into my mind then he sees us and
bolts forward and Katherine sees him too
his expression changing instantly from
grave to beaming now waving at us wildly
he breaks into a run and so do we the
scene I'd imagined so many times coming
to life my father folds his arm arms
around both of us at the same time oh
Dad Katherine says we were so worried
about
you my stepmother stands by astonished
that the two of us are so calm in her
words no crying no tears ready to
go nothing about him said The Aviator in
The Little Prince gave any suggestion of
a child lost in the middle of the
desert decades later researching the
book I asked my father did you ever
think we were going to die no he says
right away I always knew you were coming
back not for a second he tells me did he
think
otherwise my stepmother remembers it
differently though she describes my
father during those days and nights as a
man on another planet at once stoic
Frozen and devastated was he thinking of
never getting you back she says well yes
killed and never coming back oh
yes and the last bit I'll share this
afternoon takes place in the summer of
2019 so this is your first official
visit to Jordan says our guide Salah
klya Trim in his blue jeans and short
short sleeved green shirt though his
degree is in economics Salah has a
special interest in Travelers who care
about history and
politics the makeshift desert airst
strip no longer exists now buried
beneath the buildings of a recently
constructed defense
plant at the security station that
blocks the entrance men emerge shake
hands speak in Arabic I can see Salah
gesturing toward me explaining why I'm
there he comes back to the car to say
that the plant is a completely
restricted area that it's impossible to
gain
entry the security men have given Salah
directions to an unrestricted High Point
and we head south then West our driver
pulling onto a narrow paved road then a
dirt road until we come to a stop near a
trash dump with feral dogs scrounging in
the
detrius it's 8:30 in the morning and
it's already hot as we crunch across the
powdery lime that covers our shoes in
white dust
you were on your way back to the place
where you landed The Aviator asked The
Little
Prince at your time in 1970 this was
just desert Salah says almost 50 years
later I stand on the ledge looking North
over a flat expanse of scrub a steel
factory and parts of a petroleum
Refinery rise to our West the newest
part of the city of Zara spreads out
behind us the sand I think would be in
that area Salah says pointing to a low
Ridge and the hills farther on
then you don't remember said The Little
Prince this is not the exact
spot comparing the coordinates of the
satellite image to a cell phone Compass
Bruce my husband with me that day
determines that we're less than half a
mile away we're standing on the crest
where reporters coming from a caught
sight of a three airplanes laid out like
children's toys or three dots on a
domino envisioning Katherine and me two
young hostages Bruce loses his composure
behind his sunglasses
an occasional brush of wind relieves the
solid morning heat which suddenly seems
familiar I remember that it was hot like
this I say the airplane doors were open
and sometimes the breeze would come in
Bruce is taking pictures panning with
his
camera take your time guys not to rush
Salah says you can tag the photos with
your location yes they'll be GPS tagged
Bruce says steadying his voice this is
where the sun came up he observes
pointing to the
east after such a nightmare Salah says
to come back and see the place where
these things happened is something this
is the advantage of being a child at
that time because you hadn't any idea
about what's going
on we stood on that ledge for a little
more than half an hour look at it
carefully so that you will be sure to
recognize it in case you travel someday
to the desert said The Aviator in The
Little
Prince I'm ready to leave the thought
comes to me I don't ever need to come
back here again
I say it feels like it happened to
someone else thank you for
listening thank you Martha um that was
that was wonderful and um if I can just
say I you know I had heard Martha give
uh talks from the book and I discussed
it with her and I I really wasn't
prepared for how moving I found the book
uh to be as I read it this summer I I
you know I knew it was going to be
fascinating historically but um I I it's
just an incredibly gripping read and
it's also just very very moving for in
ways that I I'd like to try to get at um
today and in fact um the first question
so I encourage everyone to please send
in questions using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen and we already
have um a couple questions so I'm going
to Dive Right In um the first one your
eloquence and calmness in presenting the
terrifying events is striking to me I
imagine that the experience contributed
to a kind of emotional distance my
question did the experience of writing
the book bring more emotion to your
recall of the events and that is having
read the book that that is in a way what
you're after in a sense but could you
talk about that yeah it's such a
wonderful question thank you
um writing the book was was hard was
hard for me emotionally um I was a
fellow at the Coleman Center for
Scholars and writers when I began
writing this book and I had a wonderful
support of a cohort of fellows um who
are writing different kinds of of Works
non-fiction fiction history poetry and
um at the end of our fellowship Year
I'll just share this story um one of the
fellows who was a very emotional person
and who would often um you know she
would she would cry in the middle of a
conversation or at lunches and so she
joked at the end of the fellowship year
um I think I'm the fellow who's cried
the most during this year and then I
said to her well that's that's if you
don't count crying alone in our offices
so so writing was very hard um
publishing the book was hard it was also
hard for my sister who was so incredibly
supportive and amazing during the whole
process and read the
manuscript um talking about it it's so
interesting talking about it um I have
to in a way assume that kind of calm I
don't know if I call it Det atted but I
have to be the writer talking to an
audience but I've also found that since
the book came out I've experienced other
kinds of of of emotional troubles and
you know we always think of Memoirs as
somehow
solving past anxieties and I almost
found it to be the opposite writing the
book was was I'm really glad I wrote the
book and I'm really glad I researched
the book and and that my sister shared
the experience with me but having the
book come out and having the book be out
is actually quite difficult so
um the questioner is is correct that
that my demeanor is um is is you know
something that
um I'm very conscious of of having to
um having to assume when I when I talk
to groups and talk to readers and people
which I very much want to do and very
much enjoy doing so so thank you for
that question
and uh another one it uh you said it
felt like it happened to someone else um
and that's a striking sentence as a
historian would you say that you've
tried to help people feel like things
happen to them also a wonderful question
thank you and I I say it's a wonderful
question
because I wanted to write a book
that somebody could read without having
had the same kind of atic experience I
had and that it could speak to people
who um maybe especially people to whom
things had happened as children that
they were not encouraged to talk about
at the time things they didn't
understand that happened to them as
children and now of course we're
grown-ups and we can go back and try to
make sense of some of the things that
happened to us and what I found was um
in a very gratifying way I have received
messages from readers who experience
very different kinds of very sad events
as as young people quite a few from from
people who lost a parent as a young
child and some in very traumatic
circumstances one from a reader who was
a very young child in a car accident
that that killed her mother but she was
a Survivor and nobody ever talked her
about it I also received an incredibly
incredibly moving message from from
somebody who had been violently
assaulted in a in an incident that he
named as gay bashing was in the hospital
for four months and wrote in this
message that although you know he said
they fixed me up pretty well physically
he was still trying to deal with it
emotionally and all of these messages
said you know your book helped me think
about these things I didn't want to
think about before or some of them were
from people who said your book reminded
me of the process that I went through
when I at first didn't want to think
about things and then turn to them and
so that was really important to me that
the book could transcend its particular
trauma and topic and speak to readers in
that way yeah that's what I mean I lost
a parent uh very young and then very
quickly decided that um you know that
was something I had moved on and that
was the part that really resonated for
me you know that you went back to school
and um acted like everything was okay
and I I remembered something very
similar I'm wondering whether um the the
kind of work on trauma was important to
you as you wrote this and
specifically um the idea of kind of
delayed onset
PTSD and you know Freud talks about the
concept of noct trite and a kind of um
where as I understand it a subsequent
event can
trigger um a feeling of trauma related
to an earlier event that you didn't
necessarily register as trauma at the
time and it made me think of your
experience of 911 as that that kind of
second event here I'm wondering if that
any of that kind of trauma theory was
important to you yeah so um I have a big
long bibliography in the back of the
book and um readers who who skim through
it will see that I read many
many professional Journal articles from
psychology and Psychiatry journals about
trauma what was what was tough was that
um very few really none of the Articles
were based on the kinds of experiments
or circumstances that replicated our own
so articles about trauma and children
are usually about um sexual abuse or
witnessing an accident something like
those were two common um common
phenomena that were often in these
articles there there is one um wonderful
writer um and psychologist who wrote
quite extensively about children who
were on a hijacked school bus and
although it was very different her work
was very important to me um so that that
was incredibly important to me and I did
learn from it but it's also important
and I I do write about this in the book
that you know PTSD was not named until
10 years after the hijacking it was
named in 1980 now of course it happened
and you know I'm a civil war historian
people talked about soldiers and um
shell shock and all of that uh kind of
obviously people were aware of it but it
wasn't named and what I noticed in doing
my research was
that all kinds of authority spoke about
the event kind of like you were saying a
moment ago myy about about your mother
as if it's over and that's fine and so I
was astounded to hear a newscaster just
say the words and now their nightmare
was over when we got home um I I also
found that I very much um took on that
narrative myself so one of my favorite
examples during my research was um my
best friend in Israel uh was kind enough
to share with me the letters that she
and I had written to each other at after
we got home and in one of them I wrote
to her it was the first letter I wrote
to her after I got home and I you know
wrote her a few things didn't say
anything about the hijacking and then I
said I'll write you a longer letter when
more things have happened you know as if
nothing had happened um and so I also
talked to friends of mine I was entering
the seventh grade who I talked to
friends of mine in seventh grade and
what their memories were and one of them
said very very poignantly she said to me
the impression that the girls in in your
class had was these are her words no
harm done no lasting effect so I was
very
determined not to absorb what had
happened to me and that was the way for
me to prove I I believe now to prove its
insignificance to myself um and part of
it was about protecting my parents I
didn't want them to know that I had
suffered because I knew that they had
suffered so you know this is the
challenge of writing about childhood
trauma and childhood memories um and all
of that was part of the process of
researching the book writing the book
and then also thinking about the book
since its
publication okay we have quite a lot of
um questions now so um one so you talk
about how Holocaust Survivors
experienced the the hijacking um do you
make the distinction about being a young
Jew having this experience versus
elderly people repeating a trauma that
was particularly Jewish yeah that's a
really interesting question I I wouldn't
say for sure I mean you can read the
book in different ways I think in my
reading the only way I make that
distinction is by saying that my sister
and I knew there were Holocaust
survivors on the plane and they had
often been children during the Holocaust
we didn't know them well but we knew
that was true because we heard people
talking about it and that we felt very
sorry for them now as I said in in my
talk we also felt sorry for our captors
who had been children when their
families had lost their homes and so in
a
way and I think I said the I think I
said the line from the book we felt
sorry for everyone um and of course I
did talk about you know that my sister
and I were different from other American
Jews on the plane so in a way I was 12
my sister was 13 we were trying to make
sense of all of this I think we were
empathic children in our own ways and so
um I didn't I don't believe I made a
distinction in the way the questioner
asked and it's a very interesting
distinction was more a matter of trying
to understand the circumstances of
different people in our midst captors
and captives and again kind of wanting
to solve everybody's problems but not
being able to think of a way to do that
and I the last thing I'll say and I'll
I'll try to keep my response is short
because there are many questions but um
oh I'm sorry never mind I I don't even
remember what I was going to say yeah I
I do feel like there are those moments
in the book where you know the um uh I
don't think this is my own projection of
the reading where you're talking about
especially in the part the you know
where um they ask you whether you're
Jewish um the hijackers and that did I
think I'm not imagining this that you
bring up that in relation to the to the
Holocaust in in the book yeah so I'd
like to just say a little bit about that
it's very important um there was the
second night we're on the plane Monday
night that was the one time where the
Commandos questioned the hostages and
asked each hostage if they were Jewish
and my sister answered for us and she
said yes um and then what happened that
night was quite frightening it was the
the most frightening moment of the whole
hijacking where you know people were um
taken outside to the desert it was
nighttime and you know there were armed
Commandos around us and then what
ultimately happened was a number of Ho
Fair number of hostages were released
from our plane the only people who were
released were not Jewish um the fact
is the Jews whose names were called
called or sent back to the plane but
very important and I discovered this
during my research um there were still
many many non-jews who were on the plane
and who were retained the whole week and
our captors also kept about 50 hostages
longer for two weeks longer and about
two-thirds of those were not of those
people were not Jewish and also the same
night that the some of the non-jews from
our plane the TW TWA plane were sent on
to Aman Jews from the Swiss
airplane were were released and that
Swiss airplane had not made a stop over
in Israel and people surmise that might
have been why um so so what I write
about in the book is one of the enduring
myths of this hijacking is that our
captors separated Jews from non-jews
held all the Jews and let all the
non-jews go and that's simply not
true but I do concede that it was a
frightening moment on Monday night and a
confusing moment and that's I think why
that myth
um endured you know I I also should say
that after that night and I you know
this isn't just my analysis but this is
from my research there was never any
distinction made between Jews and
non-jews um our captors did make a
distinction between Jews and zionists
and they were very clear about that and
occasionally when they would interrogate
people they would ask them about their
um views of Zionism because that was a
way so what they were trying to do when
they were asking these questions was to
deter who would be a valuable Hostage to
hold longer because they wanted to
exchange their hostages for Palestinian
prisoners so a complicated complex
situation and I feel strongly and I do
set this out in the book that all the
facets of it need to be
understood and they also is as I
remember were very interested in certain
Americans especially on your plane there
was an African-American like who was in
the Army maybe who was kept the the
whole time and um there were two maybe
people um anyway yeah you you yeah so
some of the other hostages um you're
referring to an African-American Soldier
a man named lennet Cain who was kept
longer um and also I think you're
probably referring to there were two
diplomats neither of them were Jewish
one of them eats like a secret message
yeah so there was um I didn't know this
at the time but um what I learned was up
in the air while the hijacking was
taking place this these were two State
Department officials and um one of them
had his notes some notes with him and
you know just as a kind of diplomat's
fear he ended up ripping them into
little pieces and then swallowing them
and I you know I read that in one source
and then it was corroborated because
historians always want to corroborate
stories um in another source in which a
woman told me that her eight-year-old
son said to her up in the air mom why
are those men behind us eating paper so
I knew that that had happened so um
people were kept for different reasons
um the hijackers were also interested in
um Americans on our plane who had dual
Israeli citizenship and there were
actually very few of those and one of
the reasons they were so interested was
because um one of the other hijackings
that day had been an L plane that did
take off from Israel and there were of
course many um Israelis on that plane
and there was a real dir of Israeli
citizens that they could leverage to
trade for Palestinian prisoners and so
they they trained their sites on Dual
citizens of which there were actually
very few on our plane and you're you
write about how your sister answered for
you when they asked if you were Jewish
and she decided to say say that you were
Jewish but she didn't totally tell the
truth that you were visiting your mother
who lived in Israel right yes that's
exactly right so she said we were Jewish
and then one of the questions that that
they also asked each hostage that
evening was why were you in Israel and
what my sister said was we're visiting
our grandparents now my grandparents did
live in Israel that summer and that was
true but something stopped her from
bringing up that our mother lived there
it felt too close and a little too
frightening to her and I think she felt
um you know she had no intention about
lying about being Jewish but she wasn't
lying to say that we were visiting our
grandparents she just wasn't telling the
whole story and that might have been
smart because then they might have
assumed that were dual Nationals in some
way might I mean it's interesting more
you're quite right the fact is and I do
write about this in the book The the the
C our captors were quite kind to the
children on the plane um that was not
the experience of all of the grown-ups
by any means especially the ones who
were interrogated um which happened by
the way at night when we were asleep and
I had no idea this had happened until I
was researching later but they you know
they let us outside for a and exercise
they jumped rope with us they sang songs
with us they gave the little kids piggy
back rides you know we're in the middle
of the desert we can see the we can see
water on the horizon because it was a
mirage and I had just learned about
mirages in sixth grade and one of the
Commandos you know knelt down on the
sand and explained the scientific
workings of mirages to a group of
children so um they were they were not
personally frightening to us as children
yeah so this you've answered some people
have asked questions about whether your
Recollections were different from the
other passengers I think that answerers
here's an interesting question um you
speak sensitively about the events that
influence the hijackers political views
in what ways do you think your
experience helped shape what I take to
be your political views of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict yeah it's such an
interesting question you know don't
forget that I never thought about the
hijacking for years and years and years
um when I was researching I I mean I I
knew obviously I was up on current
events in terms of Israel
Palestine I would say my sister who was
only a year and a half older than I and
just so smart and so Savvy I feel like
she so the thing about my sister which
is so amazing and this is in the book is
she was so um she was so Keen to be to
never to deny how incredibly frightening
and traumatic this experience was she
would never deny that I was the one
denying that she ALS Al was
simultaneously able to hold in her mind
and in her heart this incredible empathy
for our captors and she she does that in
a way that's that's unusual and very
human and very admirable and I think in
some
ways I did that too but I did it by
suppressing much more ideas about my my
feelings about fear and then when I you
know really began to research the
popular front I mean look first of all
you know the popular front was a
revolutionary minority Within the PLO in
1970 and the rest of the members of the
PLO which made up of many faction
factions in many groups did not support
the tactic and strategy of hijacking and
they were quite infuriated with the pflp
so we can't take the pflp as
representative um of Palestinian views
at the time they were looked on with
disfavor by fellow Palestinian
insurgents um nonetheless you know
researching all of that in all of that
context um I think it clarified for me
some of my own views about situ the
situation in the Middle East which as a
historian the last thing I'll say you
know historians we we thrive on
complexity and you know the trouble with
many dialogues about Israel Palestine is
that neither side wants to face the
complexity and so I try to do that in
the book and maybe the fact that people
on both sides have been disappointed
with the book in certain ways or maybe I
should say the extremes of both sides
people have been disappointed that I
wasn't straight out pro-israel and you
you know in all of my renderings of this
event and others were disappointed that
I wasn't more sympathetic to the
Palestinian plight um I don't think it's
that I'm not taking a stand but I think
it's that I'm trying to trying to
present the nuance and the complexity
and that's hard to
do um so someone writes uh both you and
your sisters seem to have had a
dispassionately mature response to the
hijacking at the time um you were
considering the plight of the hijackers
um did you later experience um um PTSD
in the sense and has I think I know the
answer to this has the experience
altered your views on terrorism or
hijacking you know generally yeah I mean
so you know PTSD wasn't named but it
doesn't mean it didn't exist and so I
read about the symptoms and I read about
these conditions um my sister and I
would not have been diagnosed with PTSD
when we came home we would have been
diagnosed with something called acute
stress disorder which is much more
short-lived so we did we had bad dreams
and you know there we had certain
symptoms that absolutely did affect us
but um some people would have been many
people would have been diagnosed with
PTSD but not everybody um so that's
that's the first thing um I should also
say that I had and still have despite
researching and writing this book flying
on airplanes which I do very frequently
is is still very difficult for me um and
you know
still genders a lot of anxiety so I
completely willing to admit that and
tell me the second part of the question
again you know did it change your view
of of terrorism and hijacking I seems
like 911 is a motivating factor of
you're writing the book right um yeah
yes I mean it's so it's so interesting
because um the the word terrorism is is
a complicated word and I'm just going to
say a word about this because I am a
historian I care about the historical
use of that word and you know experts
disagree on the use of that word um and
historians puzzle out the history of the
word and I was very interested to find
that in 1970 the mainstream press so
like the New York Times did not use the
word terrorists much at all so gorillas
right didn't they call gorillas and so
the words I use in the book I do use
Commandos
um gorillas captors I use all of those
words um just to give one example
there's a New York Times headline from
September 10th 1970 that reads popular
front most militant Commando group so
you know and that was I I got the word
Commando actually not from my capts but
from the press and I wanted to be
historically accurate and you know
people have written about the trajectory
of the word terrorism um you know the
hard part about the word terrorism is
for whom do you you use it and and for
whom do you not use it and so you know
the the leader of the and founder of the
popular front for liberation of
Palestine George habash Who by the way
was was Christian um was not Muslim um
you know he he would say that terrorism
was and these are his words was what
made of us refugees so it's a
complicated term um I mean obviously I
didn't condone 911 or the Munich
Olympics or what happened and T or any
any of those things um and you know even
when we came home and I have this
conversation on tape and somebody asked
my father you know how do you feel about
the gorillas I think is what the
questioner said and my father said you
know sympathetic to their cause but not
to their strategy and tactics um and so
that also I think was was meaningful to
me that my father could say those words
at the
time okay I we're almost out of time I'm
gonna take uh the privilege of asking
you the last question um myself which is
um very interesting part in the book
where you cite the hijackers saying that
they were anti-zionist but not
anti-semitic or anti-jewish I think um
uh and um you know this of course is one
of the main questions facing
anti-Semitism studies now when does
anti-zionism turn into um anti-Semitism
I'm just wondering if you could explain
a little bit how the hijackers saw that
difference and how you deal with it in
in the book yeah so um thank you for
that my the the popular front was very
clear that they distinguished between
Jews and zionists so this is what they
said I mean you you can take it as you
wish but it is their position papers
habash who I mentioned before their
founder and leader um when the hijacking
happened he had recently said to a
reporter that the pflp was quote not
hostile to the Jews as Jews and did not
aim at annihilating them or throwing
them into the sea
so and and further quote we Harbor no
hostility to the Jews but we shall fight
the zionists because they invaded and
occupied our homeland now obviously
that's a very loaded statement for many
people I will say though that
um from Reading interviews with my
fellow
hostages many some or many of them seem
to come to an understanding of that
during the week so you know one person
told a repor well you know they like the
Jews but they don't like the zionists or
you know they said they could live with
the Jews as long as they were
non-zionist
um and so you know that that distinction
isn't um one that everybody would make
but the thing that was interesting was
when our captors asked us that one night
when they asked you know what's your
religion or are you Jewish um you know
that was something that in a way was was
a tactical error and I in the book I
quote This Man William Quant who was
from from the National Security Council
who said you know he put it this way he
said you know the pflp didn't go around
and ask people about their political
views they simply asked what their
religion was which was quote not a very
smart thing to do if you're trying to
combat the common view of
anti-Semitism and he's absolutely right
but what is interesting is in those I
learned during my research in the
interrogations of various adults on the
plane they did actually ask people their
views on Zionism as a way to determine
who they felt would be a valuable
hostage
um so you know that I I did a lot of
reading on anti-zionism
anti-Semitism I have my own view on it
not everybody will agree it's quite
fraught um but I do think it was very
important for me to read the literature
of my captors um and at least to have a
sense of what their um official
positions were and you know I've also
talked to people who said you know they
shouldn't you know people you know they
shouldn't have asked you that question
it was just kind of a like a flawed
human being thing to do like people
don't always follow their political
strategies you know in in the perfect
way um and I I I do think they
understood after that that night that it
was the wrong thing to do so complicated
um again and there was also the
confusion that they would refer they
didn't want to say the word Israeli
sometimes to acknowledge Israel so they
would they would call people Jews even
though they really meant Israelis and so
that also you know very um confusing and
frightening to some people so language I
do talk about language in the book and I
I actually have a i it's so important
that I invoke a quotation from The
Little Prince talking about you know I I
don't know the exact quotation now but
but that language can be confusing and
can cause harm and so all of those
aspects um made it in a way and maybe
this is you decide if it's an ending
point but in a way those complexities
and nuances made it possible for people
to understand the event
in whatever context they brought to it
before it
began yeah so so interesting okay we are
out of time and I'm I apologize to
everyone whose questions I didn't get to
um but this was such I think it's just a
sign that it's such a rich book and I
really um urge everyone to to read it
and thank you you can't hear everyone
clapping um but I will clap for you so
thank you so much uh Martha for for
sharing this with us um today thank you
so much Mory and I would like to thank
the audience all of you for all of your
very thought-provoking questions thank
you so much yeah thank you to the
audience and I hope to see you at future
yipa events so again please check out
our calendar events on our website and
sign up for our mailing list okay bye
everybody